Hey, you ever been on a date
and you notice the person
you're with might not be
"the one"?
Like, uh, if they want kids
and you don't
or they showed up
with a pentagram carved
into their forehead
and you didn't.
We rely on these red flags
to help us make good decisions
and keep our soul
from being consumed.
Mike and Dave Need Wedding
Dates is in theaters now.
It's about two guys
who miss some major red flags.
Here's a clip.
Jeanie, I am proud to introduce
our wedding dates.
-You guys look great together.
-Thank you. -Thank you.
You're so tiny. He's so big.
You take all that?
Oh. Uh...
So...
Comedians...
comedians,
what are some other red flags
that might let you know
your date is not the one?
In 60 seconds. And begin. Riki.
He's the guy
Adele was singing about.
All right, points. Tom.
You met her on ChristianMingle,
and she's clearly only a farmer.
All right, points. Natasha.
Uh, describes himself as a Trump
in the streets
-and a Clinton in the sheets.
-All right, points.
Tom Lennon.
You met her on FarmersOnly,
and she's clearly
a mingling Jew.
All right, points. Riki.
He's a child.
Points. Tom.
You met her on JDate, and
she is clearly a rodeo clown.
All right, points. Natasha.
He's waving a red flag
that says "I'm not the one.”
Yeah. Points. Thomas Lennon.
You met her on Tinder, and she's
clearly the Ashley Madison.
All right, points.
Natasha.
Uh, constantly uses the phrase
"beat that pussy up.”
Come on!
Give me some more points!